[Music]
the long-awaited the batman will finally
be released in theaters within six
months the dc blockbuster deals with the
origin story of the dark knight and
shows how he became the way we know him
today the focus of the noise story is
not only on batman's masterful detective
skills but also on the large number of
enemies he faces one of them is even to
get his own spin-off series namely that
penguin the villain embodied by colin
pharrell will reportedly experience a
similar rise in the series as tony
montana did in scarface back in the day
behind the camera the batman director
matt reeve serves as a producer while
the script is expected to come from
showrunner lauren lafranc the series is
set on the time period before while
copperpod gets his villainous name of
the penguin and which he is still not a
great deal in the underworld of gotham
city so maybe the scarface comparison
doesn't sound so far-fetched after all
it is currently not known when exactly
the penguin series will be released
it's barely been a year since the
production of predator 5 was officially
announced the project also known as
skull is intended to get the franchise
back on track after its rather
moderately rated predecessor the
predator from 2018 the filming of the
movie seems now to be completed which
will initiate the post-production phase
this was revealed by cinematographer
jeff cutter on instagram who quickly
deleted this post shortly afterwards
there's also new information about this
skull cast as two new cast members have
surprisingly joined one is acting
newcomer and musician dakota beavers the
other is dane de liegro who has already
starred in american horror story and was
also previously active as a professional
basketball player in terms of content
there is no official information yet
however it is known that there will be
no relation to the predator moreover
there is a rumor going around that a
native american woman from the
indigenous comanche people will be at
the center of the plot she has great
ambitions to become a great warrior in
contrast to the culture she was taught
if reports are to be believed the film
is set at the time of the american civil
war in other words in the period from
1861 18th
then cloverfield lane director dan
trachtenberg is in charge of the
development while screenwriter patrick
ayson is responsible for the screenplay
providing some continuity behind the
scenes is john davis who has been a
producer on every single predator filmed
to date it is not yet clear when we will
be able to see skull in theaters but we
expect it to be released in the course
of next year
prior to the release of the dc movie the
suicide squad it was already clear that
one particular character would get his
own series we are of course talking
about peacemaker brilliantly played by
john cena if you haven't seen the
suicide squad yet you should skip this
news as the following will contain
spoilers in the first image of this
series published exclusively by
entertainment weekly we can see not only
the peacemaker but also two other
attorneys from the suicide squad they
are jennifer holland as emilia hogwart
and steve aggie as john economos and
it's not just a coincidence if we recall
the end of the dc blockbuster the two of
them made sure that the main character
had the most important information
needed for the reckless suicide squad by
the end of the credits they were then
given the task of preparing the
peacemaker for his upcoming mission well
so much for the connection between the
series and the movie however these are
not the only characters we can recognize
in the picture in the background we also
see chicouti iwoji has cleansed mourn
and danielle brooks as leo to adebayo to
the right of the peacemaker we can see
the last supporter in the picture which
is adrian chase alias vigilante played
by freddy stroma
soon the time for tom holland spider-man
in the mcu will be over as the iconic
superhero returns to the sony universe
after spider-man no way home there a
number of villains are waiting to
finally stop peter parker above all the
sinister six of course but eddie brock
ellis venom certainly has a few things
to say to spider-man as well the second
movie installment venom let there be
carnage will be released in october
after which the future of the anti-hero
remains uncertain much to the delight of
many fans venom 2 director andy circus
confirmed to ign that crossover
involving venom and spider-man is now
just a matter of time sadly he couldn't
tell us when exactly and in which way so
it looks like we will have to remain
patient for a while for the time being
there's more news about venom levy
carnage since a couple of days ago the
runtime of the upcoming blockbuster was
revealed according to a report from
screenrant the sony adventure is
surprisingly short as it is said to be
just over 90 minutes long this is a true
exception in today's movie world where
films like avengers endgame can keep you
in front of the screen for nearly 3
hours regardless the short running time
means that we can expect compressed but
hopefully all the more intense action on
the big screen venom leatherby carnage
will be released on october 1st 2021
director olivia wilde published the
first teaser for the upcoming thriller
don't worry darling on twitter a few
days ago the short clip shows us first
impressions of the two main characters
played by harry styles and florence pew
the story is about a traditional married
couple from the 1950s the life could
hardly be more idyllic or at least so on
things at the beginning of the trailer
it quickly becomes clear that there's
more to the story and we see disturbing
images that are more reminiscent of a
horror flick particularly striking is
the creepy song that's played in the
background sung by florence pew herself
we think that the teaser definitely wets
the appetite for more director olivia
wilde had her breakthrough as an actress
on the teen series doc others may also
know her from the niculada biopic rush
which came out in 2013. how she
succeeded in directing the new thriller
and what dark secrets shake the suburban
ideal is something you can find out from
september 23 2022 in the us at least we
will keep you up to date on the latest
news about don't worry darling as always
christopher nolan and walnut brothers
can look back on a very successful
working relationship having started in
2002 with insomnia the star director has
created long-running hits such as the
dark knight interstellar inception and
more recently tenet which many viewers
found rather mediocre however after
almost 20 years it is now time to call
it quits the reason behind this is both
simple and trivial like many actors the
director is bothered with the release
practices of walnut streaming service
hbo max since the publisher has released
all blockbusters of 2021 not only in
theaters but also on hbo max at the same
time many of those involved missing out
on larger part of the income the big
winner in this strategy is solely warner
itself which is why many have harshly
criticized the company's behavior in the
past so much for the context though what
are nolan's plans now at universal
reportedly the next project is a movie
about a rather touchy subject namely the
development of the atomic bomb it
centers on the american scientist julius
robert oppenheimer who was in charge of
the infamous manhattan project universal
is said to have invested a hefty 100
million us dollars in the movie which is
why no one has chosen this film industry
giant this time around allegedly sony
and mgm were among the other contenders
however they apparently weren't willing
to put up that kind of money further
details regarding the film are not yet
known shooting of the still undoubted
project is expected to begin in the
first quarter of 2022
mad max fury road created a sensation in
the movie community some six years ago
its uniqueness and elaborate visual
effects were repeatedly praised this is
something we can only agree with as the
project was characterized by lengthy
filming and complex post-production in
fact the post-production alone took
three years of work as a result the fan
community was thrilled when another
spin-off of the franchise was announced
in 2020 based on the backstory of
charlize theron's character furiosa
particularly surprising was the
announcement that the film would be
released in the summer of 2023 after
barely two and a half years well a few
days ago we received the sovereign news
that the film would be pushed back by
almost a whole year to may 2024
considering the various safety
precautions due to the pandemic and
perfectionist director like george
miller even that still seems very
optimistic although so since the team
continues to have happier less time
compared to fury road in other words we
need to be patient until we can finally
see the prequel mad max furiosa in
theaters
if you haven't had enough from the world
of movies and series be sure to watch
the new the matrix 4 resurrections
trailer in full length on our channel
which is a real must-see particularly
for fans of the first part be sure to
also check our channel to see previews
for upcoming blockbusters like jurassic
world dominion black adam transformer 7
rise of the beasts and many more
you